and what brings you ladies here tonight
well we are involved with another
project that has a very similar crew
group as this one so a few of the crew
members from this project are also
involved in ours it's called trainers
which is a sitcom about personal
trainers in Los Angeles and we're
premiering on the Fox LA in May and I
co-created Perot and accident and Alexa
is our director if someone asks you to
to write a book on coming to LA as an
actress what would the Reader's Digest
version be okay when you come to LA as
an actress two things you should know
one I stole this take fountain and to
get a day job that is very flexible yet
you make the most amount of money in the
least amount of time
Wow I just say hey I've had a lot of
life experiences as an actor you're
saying yeah really a lot of life
experiences and you break that into your
work take acting classes you know
workshop heat cast and directors meet
directors meet show runners and
television shows and clear work yes what
you don't get done and I think they help
do you have to be creative and that's
why you're doing it created so how do
people get those life experiences maybe
they're from a small town and they've
had oh you okay and they've had kind of
a good good life maybe nothing too
tragic how would you get those life
experiences in a safe way that's a great
question and I think well for him I went
to I lived abroad my one of my years in
college and I think just like a lot that
as many things that you can do travel or
taking art classes or I don't know
interacting with people you'd normally
wouldn't have interact with just going
outside your comfort zone in general I
think if I hurry go to art museums go to
movies people watch
Valen said you know generate material
think outside the box and really think
that you know nobody stops you but you
if you want to do this for Sue those
dreams and you can make it happen
misfit group of trainers who are trying
to keep their small gym alive and then
the other big equinox is an elephant is
busy and it's obviously a comedy of
silliness and funny situations and the
gym is you can probably imagine and is
this going on YouTube or your pitching
is one network form or content to a few
different networks and then it is if
we're mounted as a web series also so we
can either do the web series or the
pilot and see what happens what takes
off
thank you ladies best of luck series
okay all right